-Guys, as you know, every week,
we like to bring you
some uplifting, creative videos
wherever they come from,
from quarantine or just stuff
around the country.
It's time for
"What Are You Doing Wednesday?"
♪♪
♪ -What are you doing
next Wednesday? ♪
♪ What are you doing
-These are fun to watch.
This first clip, this woman
decides to pull a trick
on her dog,
like feeding her dog --
and just watch
the dog's reaction.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
"Wait, what's that?"
The timing is perfect.
"Uh-huh. Uh, what?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Growls ]
This next clip, it's clearly two
friends going on a road trip,
but one guy decides to do
something to the passenger
the whole trip
to keep him awake.
Just watch this.
-[ Screaming ]
[ Laughter ]
-Why? Again?
-[ Screaming ]
[ Laughter ]
-How many [bleep] times?
Let me sleep.
-"Just let me sleep."
[ Applause ]
Oh, my gosh.
This next guy,
there's certain rules you have
if you're dating or if you're
married or something like that
that you don't watch the show
without the other person.
You have to watch it
with the person.
It's just an unwritten rule.
You can't do it.
This guy found out
and busted his wife.
Check this out.
-A fricken season is
what you've watched!
-We've watched several of them.
-Damn it! The thing told on me!
-Yes! Season 2!
You watched a whole season
without me!
-Well, I knew I had to stop.
-You didn't even tell me.
-That's because it was so good
I couldn't stop.
-You've been cheating on me.
-Yes, I have.
-We need marriage counseling.
[ Laughter ]
-Finally, this dog owner
found a pretty good way
to communicate with his dog.
Watch this.
-Winston.
[ Toy squeaks ]
[ Laughter ]
What's up, Winston?
[ Toy squeaks ]
What are you doing?
Yeah?
[ Toy squeaks ]
That's cool.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-She had a good laugh too.
There you have it. That was
"What Are You Doing Wednesday?"